hey guys it's dense a founder thick hair
and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of boardwalk empire season
4 episode 6 the North Star yeah so we
actually have a lot of catching up to do
we talked about this episode and then
talk about some other stuff that's going
on but let's start off with this episode
um Nucky it starts off with Nucky we get
to see Margaret for the first time it's
kind of a guest star now yeah regular on
the show anymore surprise it's kind of
like she can't he kind of used the
excuse of of Eddie's suicide to like see
her again right talk to her and trying
like I don't know almost like be part of
her her life it was weird it's almost
like he didn't seem like even knew why
he was there I mean he forgot the phone
conversation about what he had already
told her he ordered cinnamon even though
he hate cinnamon as she pointed out I
just seen he seemed really he seemed
lost I mean which we saw I mean
thankfully Patricia Arquette punched him
in the face yeah oh yeah like this whole
episode he's just seeming he seems lost
isn't notes going on well I think it's
like with Eddie suicide that was
actually one of the people that's being
closest to ya for many many years we
don't know you know maybe besides his
brother and stuff and maybe even in some
ways more so right and now he's gone and
he doesn't really have anyone to talk to
about it right alright so I think like
he's trying to reach out to Margaret and
see if she shares the same grief but
she's moved on she's moved on her life
is going ok and and she just rather not
be a part of it alright yeah I mean he
is he this doesn't know why he's doing
anything anymore he's like lip the first
time I came down to Tampa well just to
make money but I'm just trying to build
and build on what I be it's it's the
whole thing of his enough enough I mean
she wasn't breaking bad it's a popular
theme and you know Nucky's wonder that
like when is enough enough yeah money
and power doesn't need any more money
he's only just broke or anything it's
not like you guys ain't gonna spend it
on right but it'd be boring if you stop
you know be the gangster to show would
be over um so let's talk about Eddie
suicide you know we we saw that that
that Nucky brought him into the fold
because he wanted to do more things and
so it kind of gave him this not so
important task but some someone he
trusted
handle the money you know and Eddie end
up you know first was you know happy
about it and you know ended up drinking
with Al Capone's brother those are my
favorite scenes of the season and you
know he's kind of like he's one of the
guys yeah like one of the guy and Al
Capone's brother doesn't know that he
used to be you know Nucky's basically oh
you soon bonfire yeah you know yeah well
cuz he tell the story of of getting shot
right all this stuff which is all true
but the the the light that he's kind of
painting is like more like he's like you
know like almost like Nephtys bodyguard
right which it really wasn't even though
they deserved he deserved to be treated
like that but he was yeah and then he
ends up you know getting pinched my by
that one uh that one FBI guy it was
smart who used his guilt over his
actually it's not an FBI guy he's a
click call it it's not fair p I it it's
the Bureau of Investigation I think as
he did they don't say fell yeah yeah
yeah but in the end he breaks yeah and
gives up a piece of information which is
actually not that big of a deal but I
think Eddie knows that that he at any
point hmm he can be broken and will give
up more information he'd be called in to
testify and he doesn't trust himself and
so for him the honorable thing to do was
kill him bro before he causes any more
damage yes cuz he you know he's loyal to
nut keep at the same time he's not
strong enough right to withstand
question apparent and the sad thing is
even though it's in terms of like it was
TV drama it's good like you know a
shortcut you know I punched him in the
face oh it's funny he was whining and
complaining but in real life he was X
doing the right thing he was mourning
the loss of somebody that was close to
him but he's a gangster so he needs to
man up and move on but I mean it shows
it's crazy how Meyer gave him that toes
at the end mean like hey sorry for your
friends like that was another place
another yeah I'd like that didn't even
happen it's kind of basically had to
move on right yeah yeah gotta give that
lifestyle going and yeah it was really
nice to see a Meyer and Lucky Luciano
back Charlie Luciano back in the you
know that I missed those guys I like the
New York family I like the Chicago
family it's nice to have them back yeah
and now Meyers striking out without
lucky because
look at her pull out right well he has
to I mean cuz yeah he's gonna get you
know now he can say oh no I have nothing
to do with this right to his boss right
uh but you know I guess this maybe
starts the split between Meyer and lucky
yeah because we know lucky at some point
becomes a head yeah he becomes a boss so
look he's gonna get big eventually but
right now he's yeah he's he's got to
figure out what he wants to do in a
previous episode we learn Meyer told the
story to not give how does not matter
[ __ ] yeah you know and how their became
friends it's you know not not the usual
way people become around and now Meyers
if this deal goes to might be moving
ahead yeah of lucky you know he's kind
of breaking away from we'll just kind of
interstate now yeah and then we have one
of my favorite characters Richard Harrow
AKA half face and you know he's kind of
he's in a weird spot this season he's
using in flux between being the the
hired killer guy but then also wanting
to try and live a normal life he tries
to do that with his sister but ends up
getting caught up in a bunch of stuff
and having to leave her and then now
with it you know coming back and seeing
the kid and his ex girlfriend or
whatever you would call her yeah and she
wants him to be part of their lives so
that he can be the father figure to that
kid but you know with Richard Harrow is
just not that easy no he's got issues i
mean you know i love the scene between
him and the dad ladies daddy's an
alcoholic sharing war stories facings
like look I did something searching her
girl like this bad thing happens like
look we've both done bad things on just
let me drink I'm dying you know I think
that was a good scene yeah I mean he's
got issues but I hope I think he'll stay
I don't know what he's gonna do while
he's staying but I mean he's something's
gonna happen well yeah they'll get the
old back in yes exactly back in he's
gonna stay but it's not gonna be you
know nice little families like snuck a
better tactic like hey man can you help
me Alec seen the mothers can you help me
also you got a factor in Jillian Jillian
what's the kid back Julia she she's all
tied up with Ron Livingston actor i
forgot other characters name office
space um she's trying to sell that the
place she's hooked on heroin she's the
one character that i don't i'm still I
kind of at the end of
last season was hoping they might kill
her I thought she was dead last seen
right I like gretchen Mol but I feel
like her story's done yes I feel like
she did her weird thing with the blond
kid who confronted them in the the
coffee shop I'm let me send and hurried
on the coffee shop I think she did that
thing she put her son to rest I felt
like okay it's time for her to go now
i'm not sure what what else she has left
to do I don't know say I'm gonna find
you see with the kid in everything so
it's going you know you know we have
missed a couple episodes here this when
I go back and talk about some of the
great storylines admit going on that
characters at weren't in this effort
yeah so first to start off with Capone
yeah you one of my favorite characters
yeah the whole thing with with Van Alden
and it created Al Capone's brothers you
know like I thought that was really cool
yeah I like I mean alden's just
hilarious like I love that scene when
they're you know they're doing the
they're battling it out you know with
all the guys from the the workforce and
you know he's got that gun pointed at
him and you know Capone's brother sees
him but then of course he gets out shot
Godfather style yeah Sonny style gets
shot up like crazy and that's that was
just a great scene and of course you go
to the hospital another great scene
between Van Alden and component opposed
just like everybody who's breathing on
the face of whoever's responsible as
ever i cease he's gonna wipe everybody
out yes and the thing is Capone's not
really learning lessons here still a
seat I'm not as I yeah because you know
in his brothers were the ones that were
more cooler and they were the one
holding him back and now that that you
know that guy's dead he the older
brothers dead Al Capone's gonna go crazy
because he was the one trying to warning
him and even then all that was warned
him look this is not you know let's not
fight here we have no numbers mhm he
knew what was gonna happen and it
happened anyways and then all this kind
of stuck between because he's supposed
to be working for that O'Banion guy
right another the flowers and then is
also working for Capone at the same time
and you know look at that house miss
he's got a nice manicured lawns good
yeah I mean one of the best lines in a
previous episode was Al Capone's brother
I think was Frank he say he told him
he's like he's like stick with me and
I'll put a grass on your [ __ ] law
right yeah this is it's just so much
going I think you know this show and
it's not it's not a bad
thing it's like a game of thrones is so
many characters you want to spend time
with and when we watch the episode like
this like North Star the one that was on
today we realized that it's like when
they're not there you feel it yeah you
know we feel when the capones aren't
there I mean especially you know maybe
start going talking about roasting yeah
such a great scene between him few
episodes back with seeing him and I
lucky that just at that poker table I
mean just you know when do you truly
know a man's when you play cards with
him and Nucky showed him he's like look
I take sure things yeah I'm not a
gambler like you are I'll need to fix
the World Series that's not what I do
yeah and he doesn't need that high he's
not looking for a gambling hi he makes
money to make money not making it for
some sort of like to feel good about
herself and Rothstein he'd learned that
about rosti that's why Rough thing is
not on this deal anymore right because
you know first Nucky was kind of begging
him or I'm begging but just kind of
trying to get him involved but but he
didn't you know after he saw that I mean
basically won almost all the money no
yeah we're for thought I put to her 200
plus whatever else is on the table I
mean he may be made made money than yeah
I mean so it's yeah Rothstein's out you
know I think was issuing cuz if you look
at season one Rossi ahead it's like a
mystique about him is very likely like
who is this guy like he makes so much
money but he always wins again always
wins now Nucky's kind of broken him down
being a man he's a man and now you see
Meyer and you see lucky was she on a
kind of commander and you know out of
the out of the shadow out of the
background so that was good i mean
that's other great seeing of course talk
about dr. Narcisse yeah it's interesting
done you know are done whenever purnsley
you thought the most interesting
character in the world like when he was
like kept him around like oh I don't
know I still don't even know from really
that interested in his character wishing
they were like a meathead to me I know
he's like he's not as smart as jockey
he's not obviously not as smart as dr.
Narcisse it seems like Narcisse is just
using him yeah he just muscle he's just
someone he can get back it we're not get
back but and put a wedge between him and
right chalky mm-hmm um while also you
know cuz dr. Narcisse his whole thing is
that whole like Libyan Brotherhood thing
which is funny because he's he acts like
he's just like refined gangster it's
like you're still a gangster yeah you
still could kill people some people
beaten up you just you're still selling
heroin to be right you're gonna because
you see I think it was great that we saw
is like the Harlem Renaissance we see
Harlem in its peak you know you see a
lot of african-americans walking on the
street with like nice fur coats and like
you know that heroin does get into
Harlem and you know obviously later on
the years of the american gangster movie
denzel washington was in just a downfall
of Harlem which is kind of sad to see
that he's perpetrating that yeah and
he's bringing that on which is kind of
sad yeah but he's trying to make moves
and you know yeah and you know get his
power up and I think part of that is
trying to take down chalky right John it
doesn't like chalky right now so I think
he's you know he's using him to get a
jockey I think too that singer was put
there to distract chalky hmm I think he
knew that chalky be attracted here I
think I mean she's a good singer by
think she was put there to distract rock
I don't know neelam and they got it on
at the end of every 10 get hooked up a
lot a lot alike and Nucky and Patricia
are you hooking up yeah everybody's
getting a little something another
character and story line that that
wasn't in this episode but we we haven't
talked about before was a Nucky's nephew
Eli son at call the prank that went too
far yes the one where you accidentally
killed that said one guy that was kind
of pranking him and bullying I am and
and seeing Nucky come and help him out I
mean that's the thing is Nucky he still
seeks that family bomb yes he liked the
new Jimmy you see that one thinking of
the carrier from the oh I'm gonna bleep
asli cuz he you know Jimmy he you know
the company because I'm Holly anyone to
go to college yeah when I something like
this like a new Jimmy kind of like he's
not be taken his wings like look now
what really hey you know I kind of
educating them how to lie yeah um but
that kid and the glasses his roommate
well he got screws gonna squeal he's
gonna say yeah he's gonna squeal but I
think they're gonna cover it up because
cuz Nucky paid off paint up the guys and
the thing is those guys are saying no we
can't get this guy off unless we have
someone else that's true so what they're
gonna do is put the clamp down on the
get his roommate so whatever he says
they're not gonna believe they got their
scapegoat right they're gonna be like oh
he's gonna tell you know the kids
parents like oh this is the guy no I
think I think he's does got free you
know
the question is is it going to get more
trouble is he's his father never gonna
find out right is he gonna follow in
knock these footsteps are gonna go to
college of the right thing I don't think
it's gonna go to college deter I think
that wouldn't make good drama so I'm
sure we gonna see more if his uh you
know Elena's yeah speaking of eli we had
you know Eli's obviously this season
taking up more of a leadership role man
that scene between him and that one
undercover agent yeah I was like man
he's gonna so wait no whose I've missed
the who's who's handkerchief was that
the initials I couldn't tell that was
Kessler's or was that no I think it's
his but he's different name then you
know what I think it is is I think that
in the previous episode Eddie took the
handkerchief from him oh well he's being
Tara gated so I think that Eli may have
found that same handkerchief in his in
his jacket yeah so he knows yeah like
hey how did this guy tongue with Eddie
he's not going to be talking to and
right so I think he he knows I'm because
that whole scene I think he with that
German on that letter I think he already
got that figured out so he knows what it
says I think something and he's like
giving a fake representation cuz you
know it's not about his sons I know and
he wrote that thing and he stops of
Gasol says I'm like no no Lauren it no I
that thing is probably to Nucky saying
hey Nucky you need to watch out for this
guy he brought me in I you know I had to
kill me I'm killing myself because I
feel so bad blah blah blah so I think
Eli knows and so I thought like oh man
he's gonna shoot him in the set yeah
I've seen you know but didn't happen but
I think you know I think that's gonna
play it was right there episodes there's
a good seasons interesting this season
for the first time in a while because
Jimmy's be gone for a little while now
but I mean it feels this is it's not
rebooting but it does feel like it's
trying to find it's a new groove it's
good but it's just trying it's not I
mean last season we had of course the
awesome Eddie yeah chip Rosatti who he
owned that CN that was he won the Emmy
that was his season I think now he's out
of the picture now everybody else we're
starting to get you know more Lucky
Luciano and more Al Capone's I'm always
down for ya yeah and hopefully we see
dr. Narcisse rise I know
don't to be the Harlem they tagging s or
whatever because right now we're kind of
lacking that I mean it's been teased
that he will but right now it's more of
like people still trying to make our
moves and stuff like this is boring bar
has always been a 13 hour movie every
year yeah and it doesn't really get
moving until the end yeah all the pieces
finally fit together and some episodes
are slower than others some episodes are
more set up and you know yeah saw the
show is yeah yeah so yeah I'm excited so
that's what we thought of this episode
of boardwalk empire you can post your
comments below on the website or on our
YouTube channel that's think hero pro
make sure you subscribe to that know
some checking with us chat with us on
Twitter Dennis night and talk to us
we're at think hero personally i'm at
griffin de
you